हे एवरीवन, दिस इज़ नितेश फाउंडर ऑफ़
डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी। सो सबसे पहले
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी फॉर द डिले। डिले किस
बात की आप सोच रहे हैं? तो WhatsApp चैनल
के ऊपर कुछ टाइम पहले मैंने अनाउंस करा था
कि एसओसी सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशन सेंटर की
कंप्लीट कोर्स हम लेकर आएंगे बिल्कुल फ्री
ऑफ कॉस्ट बट विद क्वालिटी। एंड आज मैं वो
प्रॉमिस फुलफिल कर रहा हूं। थोड़ा लेट
जरूर हुआ है बट आई एम फुलफिलिंग माय
प्रॉमिस। सो मैं अनाउंस कर रहा हूं एसओसी
की कंप्लीट लाइव ऑनलाइन ट्रेनिंग की हमारे
YouTube चैनल पे फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट। बस ₹1
आपको नहीं देना एंड विद क्वालिटी। इनफैक्ट
कल से ही ये कोर्स है, ट्रेनिंग है,
स्टार्ट हो रही है। एंड इस ट्रेनिंग को
मैं ही कंडक्ट करूंगा। मैं इसके क्लासेस
आपके लिए लूंगा। इस ट्रेनिंग को बाकी
ट्रेनिंग से डिफरेंट अप्रोच मैंने रखा हुआ
है। इस ट्रेनिंग में कंटिन्यू करने के लिए
इस ट्रेनिंग को कंप्लीट करने के लिए आपको
एक काम करना है। एंड वो काम है WhatsApp
ग्रुप में अपने आपको ऐड करना। इसके लिए
मैंने एक ग्रुप बनाया है स्पेशली एसओसी
एंथोजियास्ट्स के लिए जो इस ट्रेनिंग को
कर रहे होंगे। एंड उसका लिंक जो है
WhatsApp ग्रुप का इस वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में एंड पिन कमेंट में आपको
मिल जाएगी। वहां से जाके आप तुरंत जॉइ कर
ही लीजिए। ऐसा क्यों? जैसे ही ये एसओसी की
पूरी कोर्स कंप्लीट होगी ये पूरी ट्रेनिंग
लाइव ट्रेनिंग है कंप्लीट हो जाएगी तो
उसके बाद हम WhatsApp ग्रुप में ही आपको
फर्दर इंस्ट्रक्शंस देंगे कि किस तरीके से
आपको एक टेस्ट देना है। एक छोटा सा टेस्ट
होगा जो आपको देना पड़ेगा। अब ये टेस्ट
क्यों ले रहे हैं? आप चाहे तो दे भी सकते
हैं, नहीं भी दे सकते हैं। बट अगर आप
टेस्ट देते हैं तो आपकी स्किल्स जो आपने
गेन करा होगा इस पूरे कोर्स से, पूरी
ट्रेनिंग से एक तो वो जस्टिफाई होगी। वो
ऑनेस्टली आप बोल सकते हैं किसी को कि यस
आई एम स्किल्ड दिस मच। एंड एसओसी एल1 की
डिफ्रॉनिक्स के तरफ से आपको सर्टिफिकेट
मिलेगी। उस सर्टिफिकेट की वैल्यू इसलिए
होगी क्योंकि वो सर्टिफिकेट आपको सर्टिफाई
करेगा। आपकी स्किल्स को सर्टिफाई करेगा कि
यू आर प्रिपयर्ड फॉर द एसओसी एल वन रोल।
एंड मैं आपको गारंटी के साथ कह सकता हूं
अगर आपने सिंसियरली और सीरियसली इस पूरी
ट्रेनिंग इस पूरे कोर्स को करा है पूरी
ऑनेस्टी के साथ डेडिकेशन के साथ तो आप
एसओसी एल1 रोल के लिए 100% एलिजिबल हो
जाएंगे और आप उस रोल के लिए अप्लाई कर
सकते हैं क्योंकि आपके अंदर वो सारी
स्किल्स होंगी। मान लो आप एक फ्रेशर हो।
आपने बीटेक कर लिया। अभी जस्ट फाइनल ईयर
में हो या बीसीए करा, बीएससी आईटी करा।
ऐसा अ कुछ टेक्निकल डिग्री करके निकल रहे
हो या अभी निकले हो एंड आपको एसओसी के लिए
जाना है। आपको एसओसी एल वन के लिए अप्लाई
करना है। बस कुछ नहीं करना। ये पूरी पूरी
पूरी की पूरी फ्री में कोर्स करो।
ट्रेनिंग करो। WhatsApp ग्रुप में ऐड तो
हो ही जाओगे। वहीं पे जब हम बताएंगे तो
एग्जाम दे देना है। और आपने एग्जाम क्लियर
कर लिया क्योंकि एग्जाम में वही चीज पूछी
जाएगी जो आपको यहां पे सिखाई जाएगी। अगर
आपने सिंसियरली सीखा होगा तो आप एग्जाम
बिल्कुल क्लियर कर लेंगे। एंड उसके बाद आप
उस सर्टिफिकेट के लिए एलिजिबल हो जाएंगे।
तो WhatsApp ग्रुप जरूर जॉइ करना है। याद
रखिएगा। एंड मैं चाहता हूं इस ट्रेनिंग को
सिंसियर लोग जो हाइली एंथूजियास्ट हैं,
एसओसी को भी एज अ स्किल ऐड करना चाहते हैं
अपने करियर में वही करें। क्योंकि हर एक
साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल एनालिस्ट हर
साइबर सिक्योरिटी एंथोजियास्ट के पास
एसओसी की स्किल जरूर होनी चाहिए। क्योंकि
एसओसी जो होती है ना एसओसी जो ये लेवल वन
होते हैं वो एक तरह से फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ
डिफेंस होते हैं किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
अंदर अटैक्स से सेफगार्ड करने के लिए। तो
इस ट्रेनिंग में इस कोर्स में हम कंप्लीट
एसओसी चाहे वो एस एसओसी के इंटरनल्स हो
जाए, बेसिक्स हो जाए। उसके बाद आपके
थ्रेट्स हो गए, आपके मैलवेयर्स हो गए,
रसलवेयर्स हो गए, आपके फिर फिशिंग अटैक्स
हो गए। फिर लinक्स अ सिक्योरिटी हो गई,
Windows सिक्योरिटी हो गई, जितनी भी चीजें
हैं ना कंप्लीट सिलेबस L1 के हम उसको कवर
करेंगे। आपकी थ्योरी होगी, प्रैक्टिकल
होगा, डेमोंस्ट्रेशन होगा, लैब्स होंगे,
सब चीजें होंगी। तो आपको बहुत मजा आने
वाला है पूरी की पूरी ट्रेनिंग एंड पूरे
कोर्स में। एंड इस पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग की
फ्रीक्वेंसी जो होगी वीडियोस की वो
ऑब्वियस सी बात है ज्यादा होगी। आपको
जल्दी-जल्दी इसके क्लासेस भी मिलेंगे।
आपको एक सर्टिफिकेशन लेवल की ये जो कोर्स
है एसओसी की वो मिलने वाली है। अब फ्री
में इस लेवल की आपको जो ये कोर्स मिल रही
है ये मुझे लगता है पूरे YouTube पे कहीं
पे आपको मिलेगी। YouTube पे हिंदी में
मैंने देखा शायद कहीं भी नहीं है इस लेवल
की आपको पूरी की पूरी एसओसी की जो कोर्स
आपको कराता हूं ट्रेनिंग देता हूं। तो इस
मौके का फायदा उठाइएगा। मैं आपसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं। स्पेशली जो बिगिनर्स
हैं, जो न्यू कमर्स हैं, आप जब Lindin पे
जाएंगे, एसओसी L1 या एसओसी सर्च करेंगे
जॉब्स के लिए, तो आपको बहुत सारी जॉब
रिक्वायरमेंट्स दिखेंगी एसओसी के लिए।
क्योंकि एसओसी एक ऐसा फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ़
डिफेंस होता है जो हर कंपनी में एक पूरी
टीम चाहिए होती है। एसओसी आप एलोन के लिए
जाएंगे। फिर आपके सीनियर्स भी होते हैं।
एसओसी इंजीनियर्स होते हैं। एसओसी
डायरेक्टर होते हैं। एसओसी मैनेजर्स होते
हैं। सारे अब मतलब वो पूरी एक टीम है जो
पूरी उस एसओसी सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेंशन सेंटर
जो है वहां पे काम कर रही होती है। एंड
फर्स्ट लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस का मतलब होता है कि
जब भी कोई अटैक होता है तो सबसे पहले आप
खड़े होंगे वहां पे उस अटैक को झेलने के
लिए। उस अटैक को काउंटर मेजर करने के लिए
उस अटैक के बारे में इन्फॉर्म करने के
लिए। यह आपको एक पूरे एसओसीएल वन के लिए
तैयार करेगा पूरा यह ट्रेनिंग। तो कल से
शुरू हो रही है। कल संडे भी है। एंड
टाइमिंग आपकी जो है वो सेम वही होगी 6 और
7 PM वो आपको इनफॉर्म कर दिया जाएगा
WhatsApp ग्रुप के अंदर में बट WhatsApp
ग्रुप जरूर ज्वाइन कीजिएगा एंड मैं
रिक्वेस्ट यही करूंगा कि जो सिंसियर है
वही प्लीज आइएगा इस WhatsApp ग्रुप में
एंड बिगिनर्स एंड न्यू कमर्स जो है उनसे
एक रिक्वेस्ट यह भी है जब आपको ऐसा मौका
मिले जब आपको इस तरह की अपॉर्चुनिटी मिले
तो इसको गैब बिल्कुल करना चाहिए आपको
हमारे टाइम कोई नहीं था इतना समझाने के
लिए इतना बताने के लिए इस तरह के कंटेंट्स
देने के लिए बहुत प्रॉब्लम्स होती थी। अभी
आपको मिल रहा है तो आप उसकी अहमियत आप
उसकीेंस नहीं समझ रहे। बाद में फ्यूचर में
आपको शायद समझ में आएगा। तब तक काफी देर
हो चुकी हो। तो अभी समझ लीजिए। आपके लिए
बेटर रहेगा। काफी अच्छा रहेगा। एंड जाइए
WhatsApp ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कीजिए। एंड कल
से हम एसओसी की ट्रेनिंग स्टार्ट करते
हैं। मैं आपको स्टार्ट करता हूं सिखाना,
पढ़ाना। जिस लेवल जितना डीप लेवल पे हो
सकता है, आई विल गो फॉर यू। एंड आपको
प्रिपेयर करेंगे एसओसी एल1 के लिए। तो
आपको एसओसी एल1 के लिए कहीं कोई पेड
ट्रेनिंग कोर्सेस करने की अब जरूरत नहीं
पड़ेगी। एल1 के लिए तो बिल्कुल नहीं
पड़ेगी। मैं एल2 की बात नहीं कर रहा अभी
बट एल1 के लिए बिल्कुल नहीं करनी पड़ेगी।
एंड आप बिल्कुल प्रिपयर्ड हो जाएंगे, रेडी
हो जाएंगे। फिर एग्जाम वगैरह का बाद में
जब WhatsApp ग्रुप में अनाउंसमेंट आएगी,
जब डिटेल्स आएंगी तो उसके अकॉर्डिंग आप
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। फिर आप एग्जाम देके
सर्टिफिकेशन ले सकते हैं। जो सर्टिफिकेशन
नहीं लेना चाहता वो एग्जाम नहीं देगा।
सर्टिफिकेशन की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी उसको।
फिर वो सर्टिफिकेशन नहीं भी कर सकते। कोई
दिक्कत नहीं। सर्टिफिकेशन के लिए कोई
फोर्स नहीं है। दैट्स टोटली अप टू यू टू
शोकेस योर स्किल्स। दैट्स इट। तो चलिए
स्टार्ट करते हैं अपनी बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ़
कॉस्ट एसओसी एल वन ट्रेनिंग बट विद
क्वालिटी। बिकॉज़ आवर मोटिव इज़ सिंपल एंड
क्लियर मोस्ट आइदर मोस्ट अफोर्डेबल और
फ्री ट्रेनिंग्स स्पेशली इन साइबर
सिक्योरिटी। सो आई होप मजा आ गया होगा
आपको इस अनाउंसमेंट को सुनके। अगर मजा
रियल में आया है तो आपसे एक चीज लास्ट में
बोलूंगा कि इस जो भी अनाउंसमेंट है इसको
आप लाइक तो जरूर कर ही देना। एंड शेयर करो
अपने दोस्तों के बीच, अपने उन मेट्स के
बीच जो एसओसी के लिए सीखना चाहते हैं,
प्रिपेयर होना चाहते हैं। एंड जितने भी
आपके ग्रुप्स हैं, चैनल्स हैं या जहां भी
आप शेयर कर सकते हो उस वीडियो को शेयर
कीजिए क्योंकि उससे हमें सपोर्ट मिलता है।
एंड हमें आपके लिए ऐसे कंटेंट लाने का एक
इनकरेजमेंट मिलता है। थैंक यू वेरी मच।
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट कल क्लास में एसओसी के
एंड स्टार्ट करते हैं अपनी एसओसी एल1 की
यह जर्नी।